if you were forced to solve complex
Riddles In order to deactivate countless
bombs what would you do the world's
smartest serial killers have a grudge
against the Japanese government and will
stop at nothing until the whole country
gets blown to Hell unless you stop them
I'm going to break down the mistakes
made what you should do and how to beat
the Spanx monsters in Terror in
resonance these two kids they're going
to raise hell all over the country of
Japan and the two of them run and even
manage to sneak into this government
facility dressing up as one of the
workers one of them draws the letter v o
n on the floor here right before
stealing this bomb rushing to the exit
his accomplice waits for him outside of
the entrance door and the two escape the
facility six months later they arrive in
Tokyo with a mission to destroy the city
and this serious smart kid wearing
glasses tells his younger brother not to
stand out whatever happens over the next
few weeks but then they come across the
group of girls being mean to this one
girl called Lisa one of the brothers no
notices her and jumps into the pool and
she notices the darkness in their eyes
elsewhere deep down in the basement of
the Tokyo Police Headquarters A
disgraced ex-detective shibazaki sits
not realizing that he's going to be the
man who's going to be tasked with saving
the entire country and just then they
see a suspicious video online posted by
two kids wearing masks how original they
call themselves Sphinx number one and
sphinx number two and they broadcast a
cryptic message to the country they
declare that in less than 24 hours Tokyo
will go into complete darkness and large
Sparks will scatter all around the
Shinjuku area shibazaki's colleagues
thinks it's a joke but hearing this puts
him on edge for what's to come the next
day the two kids go into this building
glasses guy tells his brother that they
have three minutes until it's go time
and another 26 minutes until the power
generators turn back on but they don't
notice that Lisa is there as well and
she heads into the bathroom suddenly
across town a crane Knocks this
electrical wire causing the whole of
Tokyo's electricity to shut down and
emergency Sirens blast across the
country and the people in this building
begin to evacuate with the cameras now
turned off the two begin their
devastating plan and start placing these
cuddly toys all around these support
pillars apparently they're gonna blow
them up with cuteness and just then we
see Lisa exiting the bathroom and then
she bumps into one of the brothers and
she locks eyes with his cold stare he
smiles and gives her a toy that he's
holding and tells her to not let go of
it until he says so and leaves Lisa
alone confused and scared back at the
police station their power has gone out
noting the time shibazaki begins to get
even more on edge and thinks that this
is no coincidence he begins looking more
into the online video from yesterday and
that's when the emergency generators
turn on and the power is restored and
glasses guy here flips the switch and
waits his younger brother enters onto
the roof and tells him that Lisa caught
him and so he gave her one of their toys
in case they want to kill her too the
older brother looks at him with an icy
stare right as the toys inside start
melting and the rest of the building
quickly begins to blow up the brothers
then call Lisa and tell her that she can
die where she stands or become an
accomplice in their operation terrified
beyond belief Lisa agrees to work with
him and then she is given directions on
how to escape the building whoa okay if
I was these bad guys then I might have
just slit Lisa's throat and left her to
die instead let me explain the sound of
the fire alarm would have reached the
bathroom and the sound of those things
are freaking loud they're as loud as a
plane taking off so Lisa coming out of
the bathroom acting oh scared and
confusing oh what's going on could
actually be up front we cannot be caught
and also why are they not wearing masks
like why would you assume that the
cameras were off just because the power
was cut they live in Japan Japan has
over 1500 earthquakes a year folks which
means that they are probably set up with
backup batteries I would have done two
things differently first I would have
recruited a makeup artist for this job
and would have made them cover parts of
my face that are the most identifiable
to facial recognition such as getting
some prosthetic eyebrows nose eyes all
that fun stuff and then I would have
murdered that person right after because
by suddenly applying Prosthetics to the
face I would have altered my first layer
of identity upon first entering the
building and then I would have brought
along an actual mask to wear inside
because I gotta prevent anybody from
accidentally seeing my handsome mug and
also encountering Lisa is a whole other
issue for one her personality earlier
it's clear that she is bent but not
broken as Charles Manson wood said about
his own followers which means that while
Lisa would make a great accomplice her
loser issues means that she is too much
of a wild card to let live I can't get
caught so I have to do what I have to do
I need to kill her make her suffer but
then after I might feel bad and send her
family some flowers from an anonymous
source because hey I have manners
heading down these stairs she gets
directed to place her toy in front of
this window and it promptly blows up and
down below she sees the younger brother
waiting outside with the bike he tells
her to jump and the whole building
begins to collapse from the destruction
escaping the crime scene together he
drives her to meet up with his brother
and tells her that since she is now
their accomplice There's No Going Back
the police call an emergency meeting to
discuss the bombing event because these
aren't ordinary criminals they report
that since the fire alarm went off
before the bombing no one was killed but
due to the large-scale blackout cameras
everywhere were turned off knowing a
suspicious video surfaced online a day
ago they investigated to see if there's
any connection and this bomb expert then
says that the bomb used was a thermite
bomb the heat produced from it is so hot
that it melted the building's pillars
which are four times thicker than usual
the heat also caused the fire sprinklers
to go off but the water from the
sprinklers got heated up by the bomb
turning into steam and this is what
caused the main explosion and the blast
from this caused the strong pillars to
finally break and the building then
collapsed also this scientist found
letters in the wreckage hidden away that
spelled v-o-n and thinks that this was
written by the bombers and that's when
they began to connect the dots they
realized that these letters also
appeared at a nuclear facility six
months which means that these two cases
are now connected and put the police
even more on edge the next day the
police get alerted again that a new
video by the bad guys has surfaced
online they claim responsibility for the
explosion and they tell the country that
they've now planted a second bomb and it
can only be found if the citizens of the
country work together to solve their
first riddle they ask what first walks
on two legs than on four and finally on
three legs the cops are confused as is
the rest of us but they rushed to get to
work and they quickly find out that the
bad guys are referring to themselves as
a sphinx with a p not an F sound which
means that they are pronouncing it at
the Greek way and this matters because
after doing some research they find out
that the Sphinx monster appears in Greek
mythology and is known for giving out
riddles and was the most famous in the
Greek story of Oedipus Rex this is cute
but I could have figured out the
identities of these criminals in less
than seven minutes let me explain if I
had to be on the good guy's side for
once how they reacted here makes me that
Japan's law enforcement isn't exactly
equipped to handle these bloodthirsty
Psychopaths and I'm not even saying that
just because Japan's police force
creates their own cuddly mascot or boast
a squad of dancing officers I'm not even
kidding that is a real thing the reason
I'm saying this is because the police
force already had everything they needed
here to find and locate these criminals
by using the most basic profiling
technique because we have a video to
work with people have numerous
identifiers in order to be able to well
identify them like their clothes posture
hand gestures and even fingernails all
these details are given to us which will
allow us to have an informed overview of
what type of people these bad guys were
even the color of their hair is visible
on the screen of course they could have
dyed it but anyways their body was
exposed as well we see their exposed
arms including their non-developed
forearms and overall frame which could
have revealed to us their lack of will
muscle maturity and this coupled with
the fact that their arms look more
youthful and means that these bad guys
are likely younger than the age of 20
shibazaki tells to the police the story
of Oedipus Rex which she was about a
father who was told by an oracle that
his son in the future would kill him so
the father abandoned his kid in the
forest and later in the future the son
not knowing who his real family was
eventually killed his father and
accidentally slept with his whoa before
blinding himself when he found out the
truth and then met his Sphinx at the
process and it offered him this very
riddle shibizaki here then realizes that
the answer to the riddle is the man
itself due to the three stages in a
man's life they then try and see if the
numbers actually match up to any
corresponding address in the country and
they find one in Minato and so the
police eagerly rush off to the location
but shibazaki stays behind because he
thinks maybe something is off reaching
the building the cops suddenly get a
call by him and he tells him that he's
discovered a new clue and he reveals
that in Greek mythology there is
actually a second to lesser-known
version of the Oedipus myth that had a
different riddle in that version the
Sphinx asks Oedipus what has two legs in
the morning four in the afternoon and
three in the evening a 2-4-3 progression
because of the this shibazaki thinks the
answer is Oedipus himself he tells them
that in the myth after sleeping with his
mother edifice fell down to the level of
a beast because what he did was nasty
meaning he had four legs but later he
went blind and then he finally needed a
cane to walk Three Lakes he also
remembers that the bad guys asked the
police to solve this specifically and
means that Oedipus in this case must
actually be a police station checking
the new address that corresponds with
the new numbers he finds out that the
address is this police station the
police chief is shocked at shibazaki's
smartness and lets him in on the top
secret news revealing to him that a
plutonium bomb was stolen from a nuclear
facility specifically a nuclear fuel
processing facility in Amore six months
ago based on the letters from earlier
the cops know that these guys are the
ones behind all of this he then offers
this washed up detective a spot back on
the team meanwhile our young villains
here begin to work on the next few steps
of their plan and then notice bomb bands
at the crime scene on the news but they
also spot nuclear biological and
chemical Special Forces there as well
they think it's kind of weird and they
begin to think that the police have
finally connected them what happened six
months ago glasses guy tells his younger
brother the next bomb they plant will
help them know for sure later the cops
go through the police station cameras
and discovers this one person sneaking
in and think that this person must be
one of the bad guys they get word that
he posed as a delivery man and thinks
that he must have planted the bomb there
himself the police chief then tells
shibazaki that one of the suspects who
stole the plutonium bomb six months ago
actually worked at the facility for a
short time but under a fake identity and
they deleted their records and now all
they have is a drawing of one of the
suspects shibazaki sees that the bad guy
is just a kid and thinks that this
doesn't add up and Justin the police get
word that they found the person
responsible for the blackout
interrogating him this construction
worker confesses that he got an email
from someone ordering him to take out
the City's power in exchange for 2
million yen and shibazaki wonders why
did these such well-prepared criminals
leave behind an email that could be
traced they're too good for this and the
video evidence from the police station
why he begins to suspect that these
criminals are intentionally leaving
behind evidence and just then they get
alerted that another video has uploaded
and they propose their next riddle
what's the building next to the house of
God who solved the riddle before the
video ends one of the bad guys goes off
the script and tells the police to drag
their legs behind them until they have
to walk like a [__] afterwards
shibazaki gets to work on the riddle and
thinks that the house of God refers to a
shrine but thinks they are now talking
about a Japanese God said well they're
in Japan and he says why did one of the
bad guys say we need to drag our feet
and he thinks that this refers to the
fact that Oedipus had a swollen foot for
much of his life and then something
Clicks in his head and he realizes that
oedipus's mother had an ancestor who was
a dragon and he comes up with an insane
plan okay these Clues are starting to
make no sense and this is why I would
become best friends with whole bunch of
Japanese grandmas let me explain okay up
until now all of these riddles have been
based off of pre-existing myths and this
means that anybody with Wi-Fi would have
been able to solve this in five minutes
yet the criminals seem to be targeting
the police station specifically and also
one of the bad guys gave us a very
interesting bit of information because
they went off script which clearly shows
that despite their intelligence they're
still kids at heart which is something
that we can use since the bad guys keep
sending us videos we could use a
technique known as photogrammetry which
is the science of measuring height and
photographs and video frames which we'll
be able to give us an accurate hype
description of them we already know
their hair color from past videos their
build and now their height so we could
create a fairly accurate suspect
description of them by now at this point
their doings has now become known to the
entire Japanese public which means we
will be able to reach out to the people
to help us stop them and unlike other
countries Japan not only has police
stations but cute little mini police
stations as well known as kobans and
using these is how we'll catch them
cabins are designed to act more like
neighborhood watch groups that look
after the community and get more
personally involved in everybody's
business and they check in with local
businesses and even become friends with
the locals including those Japanese
grandmas that I was talking about
earlier the best part is that there are
over 6 000 cabins in the country and
they are everywhere which is why handing
out the description of the bad guys to
all of these cabins to their people will
double the chances of us finding these
guys because who wouldn't want to help
out their friendly neighborhood watch
group he broadcasts his answers for the
bad guys online and tells them that he's
figured out that oedipus's mother had an
ancestor who was a dragon and since
dragons are known for dragging their
feet he figured out that the most famous
dragon in Japan is a god named arahabaki
aka the god of feat this God is found in
the Kanto and tohoku regions and the
most famous Shrine Ford is located in
the Miyagi prefecture but this God is
also worshiped within Tokyo at this
Shrine nearby and is very likely where
the bomb is the police quickly rush over
to the Shrine in tow Tokyo and sure
enough find the bomb and quickly disarm
it and they saved Tokyo from yet another
explosion elsewhere the news of the next
bomb quickly appears on TV and the bad
guys C hazmat suits at the crime scene
and this confirms what they're thinking
the government officially knows that
they are the ones who stole the
plutonium bomb meaning that everything
is going according to plan the next day
the police continue to try and find out
who made the second bomb but they're too
dumb and they can't find anything
shibazaki then decides to investigate
the town where the plutonium was stolen
just to see if he can find any clues
reaching there he talks to this one
employee who spoke to one of the bad
guys the man tells shibazaki that he was
just a kid who didn't speak much but at
one time mentioned to him that he was
listening to music from a cold land and
so they had some more small talk but the
kid got triggered because he asked him
about his dad shibazaki then realizes
that the bad guys must have some daddy
issues which means this really does have
something to do with the story of
Oedipus and then he heads back to Tokyo
and there the police force receive a new
video from the the bad guys asking them
to solve a yet again another riddle at
the place where the king solved the
riddle he received a scary prophecy
whose name would you carve on its
entrance the video tells them that if
they don't solve this riddle their
biggest bomb will go off but the bad
guys didn't mention something strange
and they say that in order to get to the
location where the king solved the
riddle they must not use a staircase
made of bronze but one made of letters
instead and if the world figures out
this riddle they can find the bad guys
waiting at the king's Final Destination
but whatever they do they mustn't cheat
and then the video ends shibazaki rushes
back to the station and gets to work he
tells everyone that the king who solved
the riddle was Oedipus that his final
destination was the underworld after
being blindsided oedipus's two daughters
let him down a bronze staircase in the
Underworld but shibazake notes that the
bad guy said to use letters instead of
stairs to reach this place and that it
hits him he goes to the online video of
the bad guys and he goes down the
staircase of the comments section and
there he sees a link opening it a game
appears on screen and they see a timer
go off shibazaki tells everyone that in
the myth when Oedipus reached the
underworld he came across a temple where
he met a woman and the woman told him of
a prophecy and on the entrance to the
temple there were three rules written
know thyself nothing in excess and make
a pledge and Mischief is nigh shibazaki
thinks that if they enter the name of
the person this game is referring to
here then the bomb will be deactivated
but the rest of the police force thinks
that since the bomb was near a shrine
last time that it might be in a temple
this time not waiting for shibazaki to
figure it out they rush over to find the
bomb and shibazaki tells this one guy
that this is the first time that the
criminals have made a request it says
that the last time they said to search
for the bomb but this time they said
they must stop the bomb and they said
this on purpose on another floor the
police go through the camera tapes of
the area and identify someone riding a
bike just like the suspect who entered
the police station earlier tracking him
they see him carry a mysterious package
into this building and the police rush
over there to check it out but that's
when shibazaki suddenly remembers that
there were four rules written on the
temple in the Underworld the fourth rule
stated to know thyself and now he thinks
that the game is addressing him
specifically taking a huge risk he types
his name into the game and it accepts
and that's when he realizes that the
timer hasn't stopped going down and he
begins to panic as the game tells him
that someone is cheating accessing the
cameras in the room where the bomb is
shibazaki sees that the police are
approaching the bomb and that's when the
timer goes off and everything explodes
online and he realizes that this wasn't
real bomb but a bug set off within the
police Network set to leak all of the
police's investigation reports on the
recent bombings and they now realize
their biggest mistake one week later the
nightmare continues the police data link
has exposed how little the Japanese
police know of the bombings and now the
United States has come in to intervene
sending someone special to finish the
job the police chief gets called into
his own office and sees a group of
American strangers sitting there along
with one young white-haired girl and
suddenly another video pops up online
and another riddle where do you connect
the dots between the punishment of Fez
5889 and the angel who planted the grape
vine the bad guys then declare they have
until 8 pm tonight to solve it shibazaki
quickly figures out that the number
given is actually an old police case
File about an incident that happened at
a school there are four students who
were late to school practice were forced
to run outside in 35 Celsius weather as
punishment and ended up getting heat
stroke but the charges against the
teacher responsible were dropped and
shibazaki still doesn't know how the
heck this is connected to anything and
knows that the bad guys are now
specifically addressing the police and
then he remembers the second part of the
riddle in the Bible an angel planted a
grapevine in the Garden of Eden and this
caused the wrath of God the angel's name
was Samuel also known as the Red Serpent
and he was forced to run shibazaki
compares the Red Serpent to modern day
and realizes that it must be a train oh
my gosh it hits him the red line of
Tokyo meaning the bomb is located
somewhere along the shuto Shinjuku line
the police force rush over to find it
while shibazaki stays back and begins to
connect the dots further the first bomb
was located at the head of the Tokyo
Metropolitan government building the
second bomb was where the chief of
police was stationed and the attempted
third bomb was found right next to the
building where the former Chief cabinet
secretary worked and who is the head of
the municipal organization that manages
the shooto Shinjuku line and that's when
he discovers something huge and figures
out that all of these members took part
in a seminar together run by an
organization known as the rising Peace
Academy a non-profit company that has
attracted a lot of powerful people and
this company might be what the bad guys
are targeting this discovery of a
cooperation between political figures
and a company means that we are probably
already dead this group in comparison
seems even bigger than the largest
pharmaceutical companies in the world
specifically one known as Big Pharma
these multinational corporations hold
the key to making Healthcare accessible
to over 2 billion people worldwide and
have a strong influence over doctors
media and politicians however the rising
Peace Academy is even bigger than that
and anyone who's ever gone up against
them has mysteriously disappeared at
this point I would have stopped this
silly cat and mouse games by upping the
security in and around Tokyo because
this would have greatly reduced the bad
guy's capabilities and I'm shocked
police haven't done any of that right
from the very beginning as for the bomb
it's way too late to do much due to the
Modern Age we live in it's likely that
the next bomb is specifically going to
be designed to be activated by an
incoming cell phone call that will
trigger the explosion at this point our
best move would be to first order the
evacuation of all the passengers on the
red line trains before directing the
trains themselves to the nearest Subway
yarn if possible if you didn't know
doing this could allow the bomb to go
off in a way more controlled fashion
meanwhile the young bad guys scour the
internet online but find it strange that
no one has found the bomb yet and that's
when they realize that they also
suddenly have no signal on their phones
and neither does the whole of Tokyo this
was never part of their plan and they
begin to realize that if police don't
find the bomb that it will blow up for
real sensing something is wrong the
younger brother runs off to try and find
the train but the older brother finds
out that someone is now hacking their
laptops and he gets a mysterious text
from someone telling him that they found
them the older brother realizes who he's
up against and he quickly discovers the
Train's location figuring it out that
it's near their apartment rushing to his
station he sees the train approaching
and sets off a smoke bomb to make
everybody panic and get off the train
but that's when he sees a little girl
sitting there and he jumps in to save
her right as the whole train blows up
back at the police station the police
force gets word that the bomb planted by
the bad guys has just gone off freaking
out shibazaki rushes to see the police
chief to figure out what the hell is
going on to police chief confesses that
this wasn't his fault and reveals that a
special team sent from America recently
took over the operation and they assured
him that they would stop the bomb
shibasaki demands to know who is in
charge and then finally notices a
strange man and a girl sitting in the
corner and they tell him that ever since
the dad leak the US government doesn't
trust the Japanese to handle this and
they have now taken over the operation
and the girl introduces herself to them
as by and she will do whatever it takes
to find the bad guys the next day
another riddle gets posted by the bad
guys but this time it's a simple text
instead Julius Caesar gone to Arab at
the police station shibazaki thinks this
next riddle is what is known as a Caesar
Cipher which is a simple encoding
technique that shifts each letter down
to a fixed number of places down the
alphabet encrypting a word like say
cookie into these will come up with f r
r and LH random numbers using this
technique shibazaki decrypts the riddle
and finds us that the next location of
the bomb is at the haneda international
airport he quickly gets ready to head
over there but begins to think that this
message wasn't by the real bad guys
because the riddle is too simple doesn't
fit the mo and just then one of the
police bosses announces that the FBI has
ordered the Tokyo Police to sit this one
out resulting in Outrage and everybody
here but but shibazaki doesn't listen
and sneaks out running into his crew who
has also got the same idea and they all
secretly go against orders and head out
to the airport meanwhile the bad guys
have also decrypted the riddle and
discuss who the copycat really is
because they know who hacked them and
they think that this person will likely
blow up the bomb for real because they
are actually crazy and they come up with
an idea to use their hostage Lisa in
their plan because no one knows about
her quickly reaching the airport the two
kids then notice all of the airport
screens suddenly turn into a chessboard
and thinks that their copycat wants them
to play a game together and if they win
they'll find the location of the bomb
and the two quickly split up and begin
to follow the chess pieces on screen
meanwhile shibazaki's men finally have
reached the airport but they noticed the
weird numbers also on the screen and
they go talk to the airport security and
find out that the FBI has taken over the
airport and is behind all the weird
numbers on screen and they realize that
the FBI must have set up this whole
thing in order to lure in the real bad
guys who are also probably here too
shibazaki thinks that these numbers on
screen represent chess moves so he tells
his guys to play the game as well
because this will lead them to where the
real bad guys are meanwhile the older
brother calls up his hostage Leah who
nobody recognizes and he orders her to
set off a smoke alarm causing panic in
the airport people begin to leave but
five notices Lisa through the security
cameras and she Whispers something to
FBI guy she then tracks the older
brother through the screen as well but
suddenly soon realizes that she's
watching a recorded tape she quickly
rushes out of the police trailer right
as the older brother holds her up at
gunpoint and he asks why is she getting
in his way and she says that she's just
trying to settle the score based on
their chess game the older brother tells
her that he knows where the bomb is but
she reveals one Lord trick up her sleeve
and tells him that she's kidnapped Lisa
and is put her with the bomb and then
the Japanese police arrive and begins
shooting at this kid forcing him to run
away and come up with a new plan nearby
shibazaki's crew hear gunshots and run
to the location and they run past the
same kid the older kid reaches his
brother and tells him that Lisa's been
kidnapped and is now stuck with the bomb
and just then they get a call from Lisa
telling them that she's in trouble and
the plane is on autopilot and now the
plane is headed right to them right
where most of the innocent people are
the older brother realizes that five
must be in the control tower directing
the other planes to avoid crashing into
the bomb and Mal thinks that the tower
is crawling with cops not knowing what
to do they call shibazaki and confess to
him that the bomb is not theirs but they
know where it's headed towards gate 106
and they tell him to go to the control
room and stop the bomb himself and these
two grab an airport car and begin racing
over to save Lisa meanwhile shibazaki
rushes to the control tower with his
police buddies and he busts through this
door and quickly directs the plane away
from the crowded terminal allowing the
bomb to blow up safely and prevent the
deaths of everyone here but he notices
the bad guys through the window and they
escape with a girl the next day
shibazaki and his guys get suspended
from the investigation and he tells his
boss that the Sphinx group are not
guilty of that bombing and are being
framed but nobody listens to him and
then he goes to talk to his police chief
and he asks him who white-haired girl
really is and he tells shibazaki that
he's looked into her and has found out
that she is a former spy and this puts
the two on edge and wonder what is a spy
doing on this case and why is the U.S so
interested in this stolen bomb the
police chief warned shibasaki that this
case is much deeper than he thinks
shibazaki then heads to the public
records office to investigate more into
the officials that the bad guys have
been targeting searching around to
figure out how they are connected to the
rising Peace Academy and discovers that
they conducted something called the
Athena plan five years ago and that an
idea hits him and he rushes back to his
office there he finds an old police case
File about a young kid who injured
someone according to the report this kid
was led off the hook thanks to his
powerful dad who is a politician and was
a member of the rising Peace Academy
shibazaki then heads to that
politician's office and blackmails him
into revealing everything and he finds
out that 10 years ago this Corporation
had a goal meant to Edge educate gifted
children by putting them through
terrifying scientific experiments but to
do this the company began recruiting
smart children from just orphanages
around the country getting the names of
all the orphanages shibazaki heads off
to interview each one but runs into his
old partner on the way out wanting to
help the two team up to get to the
bottom of this mystery but through all
of this they find out from one orphanage
that years ago a government official
took one of their children but left his
business card using it they head over to
see that official meanwhile Lisa
overhears the plans of the bad guys and
here's them mentioned that they want to
get rid of her because it's too
dangerous for her so she runs away but
that's when she gets spotted and
kidnapped by five now trapped and facing
real death Lisa confesses that the bad
guys threatened her to be their
accomplice but 5 says that she should
have just died instead and mentioned
that she would not be used as bait to
lure her enemies in elsewhere shibazaki
and his partner finally reached the
government official's house but the old
man tells him that he's been expecting
them for years going into side he
confesses everything saying that he's
too old to care to hide it anymore and
he confirms that the existence of the
Athena plan is real he reveals to them
that the last person who tried to expose
this project was the minister of health
and he mysteriously died before he could
tell the police and he warns these two
that they are putting their lives also
on the line by investigating this case
the old man confirms that the
organization tried to create super
intelligent children with a smarter drug
that was accidentally developed in the
late 90s 26 children were used for the
experiment but most of them died the
experiment was deemed a failure but
towards the end the US government became
aware of this experiment and shut it
down but one little girl survived the
experiment and an American agency took
custody of her shibazaki asks if there
were others who survived but the old man
tells him that there were rumors of two
more children escaping the facility but
he doesn't know for sure shibazaki asks
for the names and he tells them that
they were never assigned to names only
numbers one of the kids was named nine
and the other was named 12 and since
this event happened decades ago the old
man thinks that the kids must be late to
Teenagers by now and shibazaki confirms
it with the police sketch from earlier
but the government official tells him
that if any of the children are still
alive they will soon die when the smart
drug side effect eventually will take
over shibazaki finds out that the person
in charge of this project was someone
named Dr mommya shocking him to the core
he leaves the government official's
house and he tells his partner that 10
years ago he accused Dr mamya of being
involved with some shady stuff but it
was never proven and it was the reason
why he got demoted in his job elsewhere
five ties up Lisa and uses her as bait
to lure in her friends and just then 12
rushes to her location but finds Lisa
with a bomb strapped to her chest and
she confesses the due to her abusive
family 12 and 9 are the only ones who
ever treated her like family but she
didn't want to be a burden to them which
is why she ran away 12 tells her that
they are glad to have met her and he
tries to calm her down while struggling
to disarm the bomb and then five
suddenly calls him up and offers to make
a trade Lisa's life and his freedom for
the location of the plutonium bomb she
reveals to 12 why she knows why this
bomb is so important the world thinks
that these kids stole a bomb but what
they really stole was Japan's first
attempt at making their very own atomic
bomb developed behind closed doors 12 is
shocked the timer gets closer to running
out desperate to save Lisa he caves and
reveals that the bomb is at their school
FBI guy that radios his man to rush over
to the location and Lisa passes out
minutes later the FBI reached the school
but run into nine attempting to move the
stolen bomb and he quickly escapes and
is now forced to come up with a new plan
the next day he hands himself over to
the police news of his arrest reaches
FBI guy at the hospital with five and he
quickly calls up his powerful boss a
mysterious U.S official and he tells his
boss that he'll be handling killing nine
before he can talk back at the police
station they interrogate him but denying
threatens them with his atomic bomb
saying that if they don't listen to him
he will destroy everything listening to
his demands nine asks for the city to to
set up a live press conference later
tonight where he plans to reveal
something shocking but doesn't realize
he's never gonna get the chance
meanwhile shibazaki still tracking down
leads heads to Dr mommya's House the man
who was in charge of the Athena project
old and now on his deathbed Dr mamya
confesses that Japan never got over
their defeat in World War II and this is
why they developed the Athena plan to
create something more useful than a
weapon but since the project failed it
encouraged the officials in Japan to
secretly create a new atomic bomb
instead a bomb that those kids stole
shibazaki warns Mr mamya that he's going
down for this but the old man smiles and
says that no one will ever believe him
and that he gets word that denying has
just turned himself in he rushes over
back to the police station but isn't
allowed to see the suspect thinking
quick he tells his police chief to not
let anyone have nine no matter what
happens the police chief then secretly
tells him the location of the press
conference and he gets ready to go there
meanwhile the FBI retrieves five from
the hospital and he tells her that they
need proof at Japan pan has started to
produce atomic bombs behind closed doors
and they need to retrieve the bomb as
evidence five mentions that her
headaches have started to get worse but
FBI guy tells her that she needs to
focus on her job or else she's dead
calling the police he asks for his team
to escort nine to the press conference
but the police tell him that part of
Nine's demands offer him to be escorted
by the Japanese police only this guy has
other plans a little bit later the place
finally light up their sirens and head
off with the nine to the press
conference but then five an FBI guy show
up and shoot the wheels off of this van
about to kill nigh but then they get
intercepted by 12 on her motorbike and
he quickly disables five's car and both
of them crash about to get a hold of
nine FBI guy points his gun at five and
tells her that she's relieved of her
duties but she quickly kills him before
he gets the chance telling him that no
one else can have nine he's all hers she
tells him that she always wanted to beat
him and now that this is finally her
chance this is what has kept her going
for years and nine tells her that uh
he's sorry for what they went through
but she tells him to live for her
because she's running out of time
wishing him good luck she shoots the
leaked fuel of this car and blows
herself up forcing nine to watch this in
sadness and him and 12 split up to
finish their mission just then a
pre-recorded message by them goes live
online announcing to the world that
today's press conference is canceled and
reveals to everyone that they have one
last bomb to go off set to go off in a
few hours and no one can stop it at the
press conference shibazake quickly gets
word that the city has begun to evacuate
but he still thinks that this isn't what
it looks like because these kids have
never killed anyone with a bomb actually
having an idea then he then calls his
super smart daughter who is also
studying to be a scientist and asks her
if it is possible for an atomic bomb to
explode without killing anyone she tells
him that if the bomb is detonated up
high enough into the air it could result
in a high altitude of nuclear explosion
shibazaki thinks that this is how 9 and
12 would be able to pull this off but
his partner thinks that they could do
this with a giant balloon checking with
the city's camera shibazaki's team
quickly low locates a balloon taking off
around 40 minutes ago and this smart
scientist guide then says that a high
altitude of nuclear explosion means that
it would be detonated in the upper
atmosphere and the radiation will
disperse into space but will have a
strong electromagnetic pulse be
generated and this will destroy all of
the electronics in Japan horrified they
get word that the balloon has now gone
way too high too high up to be
intercepted and the country prepares to
brace themselves for the end of the
modern world oh man this is nuts because
this explosion is not just bad it's
terrifying shibazaki thinks that Ian
peoples will simply just take out the
country's power grid I don't know if
he's really thinking about the big
picture here because in reality those
things need more power than he thinks
because the blast from the EMP will be
enough to kill everybody with a
pacemaker in it or is on life support in
the hospital and this means that not
only is the super smart detective here
smart he's also really dumb because this
means that even the bad guys haven't
thought this plan through enough it's
noted that the bad guys have been known
for not killing anyone in their
explosions but this one contradicts
everything they've done and since we
can't trust anyone here guess we gotta
do what we gotta do and take care of
ourselves we have to do whatever we can
to protect ourselves from any
radioactive residue that could reach us
and penetrate our skin and if I can't
find anything that would protect myself
from radiation that I might as well find
the next thing that I can insert myself
into so what I'm going to do is I'm
gonna kill my partner stab him with a
knife and then cut him up and take out
his organs and then I would just Nestle
inside like a cute little burrito or
like a Japanese Luke Skywalker because
doing this will give us the best chance
of surviving the radiation that will
fall from the bomb because that's how
science works the bomb finally explodes
in the sky and the two kids Lisa and the
country watch and sheer awe and Japan
plunges into the Dark Ages the next day
the two kids bring Lisa to the place
where they were raised the terrifying
institution run by the Athena project
and they pay their respects to their
dead friends and they thank Lisa for
being their only friend and spend the
day hanging out with her that evening
shibazaki finally tracks them down and
revealed to him that he was always there
Oedipus and was the only one who could
have figured this all out their
horrifying actions was the only way to
bring attention to this place Lisa tells
shibazaki that her mother was a psycho
and was kicked out of her home these two
were the only people that ever took care
of her shibazaki then grants their
wishes ignoring Lisa and tells them that
they are now finally under arrest but
then the U.S forces show up in the sky
shocked nine quickly reveals that he has
more bombs planted around the country if
they try to stop him with his sights set
on these two kids this military guy then
gets word from a mysterious U.S general
and he tells this guy to take the shot
because no one can know what happened
here taking orders he fires a shot
straight into twelve killing him in
front of everyone and nine becomes
Furious and gets ready to set off the
bomb in his hand but shibazaki blocks
him from The sniper's View and Promises
him that he'll make everything here show
up in court trusting him nine hands him
the remote and thanks him telling him to
remember them and he passes out for good
one year later news of what happened at
Rising Peace Academy and the
government's involvement went viral and
the world brought the real bad guys to
Justice meanwhile though Lisa goes to
visit the graves of her dear friends and
she bumps into shibazaki who also has
come to pay them a visit Lisa thanks him
for what he did and tells him a story
out to nine and says that he always
liked listening to music one time she
asked him what music he was listening to
and he said he was music from a cold
land from Iceland shibazaki then finally
connects the dots as Lisa tells him that
v-o-n is an Icelandic word it means hope
and the two part ways and it can finally
be done talking about this weird anime
for good but what do you guys think
about the video let us know what you
like about it and what you didn't like
about it don't forget to like subscribe
and leave a comment down below and as
always don't forget to check out our how
to be playlist